foreign
I can call in everybody's phone because
all of them have phones and nobody
answered me
seven members of One family killed in
one of our state's deadliest crashes one
year ago this weekend tonight the
national Transportation safety board
releasing its preliminary report good
evening to you on Brian Loftus and I'm
Denise felda 8 news now invest igator
David charns carming through those
documents and also speaking to the
mother who lost her children and her
brother David well the details are
horrific and all nine people died in
this crash last January a crash erlinda
zarcarius says could have been prevented
had the driver who caused her children's
and brothers deaths had his license
pulled
I still like I can even think they're
gone I I just I was thinking like it's a
dream or something but when I wake up
and I say no this is true so nothing I
can do about it so and nothing I can
change erlinda zakarius's life shattered
on January 29 2022 when a driver high on
drugs sped through this North Las Vegas
intersection killing her entire family
as I started screaming because I know
that it was not possible to be alive and
I know it you can see the the many cars
he was there and then everybody was like
uh screaming zakarius's children
stepchildren and her brother all killed
when 59 year old Gary Robinson drove 103
miles per hour against a red light
Robinson collided with a minivan all
seven of its passengers did not survive
no no way to say to you how I'm feeling
because I still heard from that
toxicology tests would later find
cocaine PCP and alcohol in Robinson's
system the ntsb's preliminary report
released Thursday does not name a
specific cause nor offer any
recommendation to prevent another crash
it touches on Robinson's driving history
one dotted with several traffic stops
for speeding that were reduced to much
lesser penalties investigators writing
they found Court receipts from both
North Las Vegas and Las Vegas in
Robinson's car at the crash scene one
receipt from just a month earlier
showing Robinson pleaded guilty to
speeding up to 20 miles an hour but the
violation was not yet on his record
pay or fix it and you keep driving
Zacharia says she and her husband tried
to avoid that intercession they hope
lawmakers do something to prevent this
from happening to another family what
did he take away from you
my life everything
[Music]
Robinson and his passenger died in that
crash now over the past couple months
the 87 investigators have gathered other
evidence in this case including
Robinson's history of speeding we will
bring you that part of this story Monday
night on 8 news now at 11. for now I'm
David charns 8 news now David thank you
and a tree dedication ceremony is
scheduled for Sunday at Craig Ranch Park
the organizer was critically injured in
that crash